it's been a year since we bid farewell
to glee and now Matthew Morrison is
making an exciting return to TV on The
Good Wife do I know you you don't Connor
Fox I'm from LA I'm prosecuting your
client eats he caught up with the actor
to get the scoop on his juicy new role
it's a last season and I'm playing a
really great character it kind of takes
down one of the main characters of the
show and having a fun fun time being
back on television again it's our only
element of surprise isn't it you have to
figure out of all the dozens of cookie
jars governor Florrick has his hand in
which one leave card it's an awesome
cast great writing and everyone just
shines it's it's it's a beautiful set to
be on and I love it i'm sorry it's one
of my favorite show so i'm so excited to
kind of be on it right at the end of it
is the tome that they know it's the
final season are people getting one more
emotional or they just probably think
they are I think they are I think
they're they're they're hiding it very
well but I think Giuliana is looking a
little life you know sad I you know I
know I just did it last year so yeah
absolutely